أنا محاميه الأول ومحاميه
المدافع الأول أعرفه الآن
طالما أنني أعرف بيئته التي أعرفها
له حصرا باعتباره مطلقا
أعلى المهنية لدي وأنا أعلم
وكما قلت، بيئته لم تتغير أبدا
لا تدع أي شيء يقع في الديون
هل كرة القدم نقية لديها أقصى ما لدي
كان لديه الثقة من قبل وفعل
بعد الخطأ الذي ارتكبه
كل شخص لديه الحق. كل شخص لديه الحق
أيضا لارتكاب خطأي مرارا وتكرارا
لسحب الخيوط التي كانت أكثر من اللازم
وهي ضد مدونة قواعد السلوك في
الفريق وبالتأكيد
قواعد سلوك نادي بايرن ميونخ
وهذا ما يتم توصيله بوضوح
رأى أن لديه عذر
حدث ذات مصداقية مطلقة
لا يوجد سبب على الإطلاق
على الاطلاق
شك وبالتالي
لقد جعلني هناك كمحامي دفاع و
المحامي بجانبه وكان أنا
من المهم أيضًا أن يبقى في
التدريب يبقى معه وكان هناك
كما أنه مهم للغاية بالنسبة للاعبين
يبقى في التدريب على الفور
إذا كان استيراد هذا هذا الآن
مخلفات يجب أن تكون على ما يرام